hello grammarians and historians and
linguists and friends david here along
with jake
hey and paige hello and uh i want to
continue our our discussion of the
history of the apostrophe in english and
what i'm having jake draw for me right
now is an old english king because
what's the story of the possessive
apostrophe in english is really the
story of old english
um
like how did we get this like pages and
jakes how did we get that ending up as
our possessive form in english with that
apostrophe s because it didn't always
used to be that way it didn't always
used to be apostrophe s
oh that's very nice jake
well i try
so that's king either red so okay so
when we're talking about
you know this
um the possessive
the possessive in english is is very
strange because it's this relic from
history of these forms left over from
old english
so here's here's this table this vastly
simplified table english used to have
these things called case endings
um and this is not a very this is like a
super simplified version these are all
what are called the the strong
case endings that were strong and weak
case endings for each gender and in
english we had masculine feminine and
neuter
but the important thing to remember is
that the
singular form of the neuter and the
masculine was es and that just sounds
like gobbledygook right now i get it so
let's take our king which uh in old
english would have been
king
right and so if we're going to look at
this crown well in old english they
would have just used the latin corona so
we're just going to refer to this as a
hat so if we want to talk about the
king's hat in old english
we would use the special um
possessive ending
the masculine possessive ending right
because english had a million of these
endings there was one where if you were
the subject of a sentence you would use
that ending if you were the object of a
sentence you would use that ending the
norman invasion lopped all those off
along with a bunch of english heads and
now we have a much more simplified
language for better or worse
if we're talking about
the kinning here we can refer to this
this guy's hat as
securing
which might not be the most accurate but
you know beowulf isn't around to correct
me so if we're looking at this kinning
here right the possessive ending is this
es uh if for example we had and i'm
going to draw a queen that's not going
to be as nice
so the the difference between uh so so
okay so the old english word for queen
was perhaps unsurprisingly
quen
um and if we're going to talk about
the queen's hat
we would use this singular strong
feminine genitive ending which is quena
right with an e
say quene
and that's where all of this started
okay so we have this really ludicrously
complicated system even this table is
simplified right like i've left out half
of it
um
but ultimately what it boils down to is
securing his head sequin
and as we move through history what
happens is the french invade and they
say ah this system is very complicated
let us get rid of it and they do
and it basically leaves us with by the
time we get to middle english the
following so by the time we get to
middle english we have
the king is
hata
and we have
the queen is hata and what's happened is
this um old english masculine and neuter
genitive this possessive form
has just become the norm
for everything everything is now
masculinized for better for worse that's
like everything has been simplified in
that direction
that's part one okay so hold that in
your head okay
then
so
that's middling us and then the printing
press gets invented
now all of a sudden people are writing
texts in english all over the place but
nobody knows how to spell yet right so
we've got we've got that possessive form
and then we have what's called the his
possessive
so at this point we're in modern english
right and so some some bits of middle
english and old english have fallen away
um but so for example
um
we're still looking at something like
the king is hat
but what we're also starting to see in
this one weird little period between
like the late 16th and early 17th
centuries this brief fad for this thing
where people went
the king
his
hat
and if you can imagine like
a
post-elizabethan era londoner saying
this it kind of sounds the same
to to my mind the king is hat the king
is had right like like you're losing
this this h is kind of swallowed so
nobody knew how to spell because there
was no way to spell right like samuel
johnson had not yet written the first
dictionary that's like 1720.
i'm pretty sure
um there were no standards not because
people were dumb or anything certainly
not it's just that these standards
didn't exist
like
in the great scheme of history there's
stuff that we do now
you know that 400 years from now people
are going to look back at us and be like
you used words to communicate you know
like we have no idea
so what starts to happen
is is this this thing this the king his
hat becomes more and more common um to
the point where people just sort of
understand it as a given and it starts
to get
collapsed to save space
so the king his hat
becomes
the king's hat like so
and it was just this one
weird fad usage which you could even
argue is like a folk etymology or
something made up it doesn't matter it
happened it's a tested imprint and this
is how it was collapsed
and what happened as a result of this
usage is the same thing happened to this
so the king's hat became
the king's hat
and it was just as well frankly because
if you were talking about the queen's
hat in this his possessive context it
just you'd either have to do the queen
her hat
which is
fine i suppose or the queen his hat
which doesn't
make a ton of sense and if you're
wondering how there can be just this
random change in sound in a language
without anybody orchestrating it think
of a time where you say something like
i'm gonna go to the store
i'm gonna what are you really saying
there it's a contraction of i am going
to but nobody actually says i am going
to go right now they say i'm going to
go. so words are always kind of
mashing into each other if you remember
from an earlier video when paige and i
were discussing the principle of least
effort that's what jake is getting at is
the tongue is lazy don't feel bad but
the tongue is lazy
yeah so what happened was you know this
thing became
and pretty soon everything became this
way
uh so because of this one strange little
fad what we call the saxon possessive
this thing the kangas the qanus uh
eventually just became kings and queens
like so
how elegant thank you
jake paige does this square with how i
mean this is how apostrophes are used in
english but jake and paige you all were
telling me about all the many ways that
apostrophes are used in other languages
around the world
right well i think you know
punctuation marks are tools just like
any other tools that human beings use
they can be used different ways in
different languages so in dutch
um apostrophes are used to make plurals
what for words that end in a vowel so
okay photo in dutch is f-o-t-o and if
you want to have multiple photos well
you have to throw in an apostrophe you
have to throw in an apostrophe before
the s
no good reason why that's the case
that's just how they do it
uh
conversely
dutch does not put an apostrophe for
possession so if you wanted to say
yahn's book you would just say j-a-n-s
oh so it kind of retains this
this genitive it can it retains this
possessive form right same thing with
german so how do we say how do we say
jan's book
younes
like that
okay
same thing with german german is a
little bit more conservative in that it
retains the es so
das buch might mean the book in german
and if you want to say of the book or if
you want to say the books you'd say des
buches with that es ending
tagged on to
oh the same one as in
as in old english right so since english
is kind of a cousin language to german
you can you can see which way the
ball fell on these two languages wow
that's super cool
paige any insights from danish yeah so
from my limited
you know expertise in danish uh
people who speak danish tend to
abbreviate
like all their words like everything
gets shortened all the time sure uh so
the apostrophe is sometimes used in a
similar way to how it is here
to sort of show what's being shortened
okay so in danish to say something like
take me with you mm-hmm you would say
tommy mil
tag me man
so then
you can shorten that first word in
writing by getting rid of the g
and adding an apostrophe okay this
actually doesn't happen much it kind of
has limited use but
but it's similar to how how we use it
for contractions in english sure and
like
how this possessive was formed it's
interesting that the possessive the
modern possessive in english
is just a form of contraction yeah
it's bizarre
well folks thank you so much for joining
me on this journey through the wacky
history of the apostrophe in english
thanks for taking us yeah it was fun
anytime
and remember folks
you can learn anything
david out page out
jake out